I played Magnus last week right
not playing him now though
okay we have a D4 game
Rook C1
I will admit my memory is kind of fuzzy
here
I think it's C5
trying to apply maximum pressure
there's some G5 ideas too but
C5 and G5 don't really combine that well
sometimes G5 combines better with C6
so I'm conceding the bishop hair
the idea is I get this Central bind
four months of great entertainment and
even greater sleep in rows and let's go
oh thank you Ginger
I appreciate that
rookie Yates
F3 is maybe coming
I could play Bishop F5 actually
because F3 I take take and then take
so even though the night's kind of
pinned
it's only very brief
Bishop G6 will likely come
or we trade
and Bishop G6
try and strengthen the Palm structure a
little bit
I'm gonna play this and this
it's probably roughly equal
and the plan is to double up and then
play Pawn B5
hmm
so King F2 rookie Eights
still play rookie 8.
it's a very interesting position
F5 might be coming
foreign
should still be close to equal
I'm I'm trying to play for a win
okay I think I'm winning a pawn now
okay King E3 I have check and then takes
D4
a tricky move
foreign
game
I just lose connection what just
happened
something flickered
okay
all right
let's look work
it was interesting
um interesting end game
like with Queens on the board
[Music]
it seemed like white had everything
under control but
I think once Queens got traded and I got
this B4 move in
it's only black playing for a win here
because D4 is a weakness
and
like white hats would be very very
careful here
okay
who am I playing next hicaro or Magnus
or Fabiano
last week I played Magnus
the previous week I played the Caro
my reading is kind of at The Sweet Spot
to play way up or maybe way down next
round
so we'll see
could play nihal could play do the
grishuk
I'll probably be whites
if I play hakaru I play in London
I play Magnus I probably also play a
London
no games going
what's happening
oh there's a couple games going
or not
they'll
I'm playing the lowest rated player with
one point
shout out to my opponent who's also
streaming
this means I was I was like one uh
one player away from playing Magnus
basically
that's how the Swiss pairings work
oh what to do
but this player probably won their first
game right
foreign
which means they have to be underrated
okay Knight C6 Castle Queen side
probably King V1
King B1
I might as well
oh I think YouTube for the resub
who's maybe not watching but listening
yeah I do turn off TTS during the games
okay time wise doing pretty well
these tricks don't work because after E5
I take and there's a pin
thank you
interesting
I think they'd see one
and going for like h4h5 or Bishop H6
and Bishop C4 looks attractive
there's a bishop A6
so maybe bishop B5 first
foreign
this but I don't want to allow like this
E5 move
I'm also realizing I could let you find
myself maybe in some cases
allows an 85 though
hmm
I think I'll play this move
I'm not scared of like the B3 or A3
stuff
keeping tension
out of this move
it's a very typical attacking idea
trying to open each file
of nh5 I take with a rook takes and then
Queen G5 is force mates
it's not easy for lock to defend here
yeah so Queen G5 there's 98.
how to do this
I mean
yeah this should be winning
I think H7 is a big problem
Knight goes back I go back
okay
I'm pretty clean attacking game
um yeah this is one of my favorite
openings for
especially for Blitz and bullets
a lot of just powerful attacking ideas
especially if Lock's not preparing
so that was relatively quick compared to
the
first game I played
let's watch Magnus
wow Magnus is in trouble
wait Magnus is just losing
to an FM do you play some troll opening
well you played King's Indian
wow
it's still tricky to convert though and
black doesn't have so much time
but extra Bishop
the question is how do you do at some
point in Black's gonna have to lose a c
Pawn probably
unless a king can come in
each six
watch Magnus win this
that would be insane
black has four seconds left
but Rook H1 is a nice bailout
yeah black is stabilizing
I don't know how confident I would be in
meaning this position against Magnus
it's completely winning because Opana is
on the board
but there's some annoying checks
oh but the king can maybe come back
yeah the king should come around to G7
and then Bishop can attack G5
don't draw play for the win
oh it's a draw
wow
Magna survives
okay let's watch Fabiano
[Music]
wow look at Fabiano
wow
nice move
okay take the Rook
what a position
Fabiano playing English
oh my F3
a tricky line
I guess there's a small chance I could
play Magnus
but probably not
I'd have to be the lowest rated player
with two points
thank you chimpani happy 14 months
also thank you psycho
and backwards popcorn and Alexa play
Nickelback
okay after two rounds I have more points
than Magnus
let's go
anyone else to watch here
Bortnick
should be winning
yeah last week Magnus quit after the
second round he beat me and then he quit
but maybe drawing that last game will
motivate him more
yeah
could be seven
a nice pre-move
okay
so a lot of these games wrapping up
yeah this game list okay
looks like this is the last game going
crazy position
yeah I would love to have a rematch
against Magnus
he played the bird opening against me
last week
I showed um I actually showed Yasser
sarawan the opening and Yasser
gave some thoughts like he he showed me
the improvements
so I'm I'm more prepared
I need two
black is still kind of fighting
I should be winning though for whites
time wise Anything Can Happen uh oh
okay this [__] King C3 was in this
sir
and these pawns are so solid
E3 is about to happen
or not
this is move 116. wow
long game
I have three
Chuck
on legal move
okay
so I will be playing someone higher
rated next round
but probably not like a top player
just the way the pairings work
about this person
ever heard of this person
okay
um
this is what Brewington played against
me and this chest could match
and queen C7 looks logical
I don't know Theory here I should have
checked the theory
it's playable though
Bishop B7 there's Queen takes which is
kind of annoying
and queen A5
maybe D6
nice move
okay
it's a crazy line
hmm
this might just be losing I think I'll
go for it though
so after takes takes check takes takes
takes for creates
well I just spent my whole time
calculating
I mean King D2 I take and take and taken
pin
so I do win The Exchange
but white gets the defended Pawn on E7
the good thing is I'm preventing Bishop
B5 in the end
I ever see it
a more active move
a rookie is probably preferable
oh wow
ah so E7 is
a Target
C6
I shouldn't be so much worse
I'm giving back the exchange
oh
and this Rook D6
[Music]
um
should be four
so Rook A6 I can take on D7
be down upon
wow
nice move
okay
ah good game
that was a nice move
workout seven very good tactical vision
I mean I will say when I'm playing king
of five it felt like I was fighting
like getting counter play and it's not
so easy for white to clean the pond but
yeah this is a great way to simplify
I can't stop Bishop B7
what to do
I should really check the opening
what to do after castling
oh D6 immediately
the queen C7 also playable
this move I did not consider
so this line was playable but I think
based on what happened in the game black
is still just worse
yeah my opponent actually played very
cleanly
it was still playable
and
I feel like the accuracy was high from
both of us like I made one one obvious
mistake with King F5
I guess already it's a bit difficult
can I do game review
I just want to see the accuracy
at 91 to 80.
I'm is a miss
yeah the engines
very low depth here this is
probably not fully accurate
okay
well two out of three
did Magnus pass me
or did Magnus withdraw
control F
abiano's three out of three
oh yeah Magnus has two and a half out of
three
let's watch this game
wait what
oh light's going this way okay that
makes sense
yeah this is a draw
yeah nice move
don't play King F3 okay there's a funny
line uh if King F3 white is winning oh
White's winning multiple ways Queen B2
also wins
okay
or King C6 not King F3
all right uh let's play D4
and go for a London here
Knight D7
not the most common move
the very strange play from Black
hmm
I'm just doing my normal thing
yeah so Bishop C7 is coming
um might as well play E4
maybe this helps black more than helps
me
still looks Pleasant
yeah G6 I think would be a big
concession
that's also some confession
I have the bishop here
the Box only Bishop is not so happy here
tricky move
pretty Queen G4
those pawns attacked in two directions
and
not defended though there is this move
okay if I take
yeah this should be fine
hmm
and queen H4 is nice hits the pawn hits
the Knight
it also covers E4 so after it takes I
can play Bishop E4 defending the Rook
and then three different things will be
attacked
Queen G4 I take like everything's
defended
what happens after this move
Yeah It's Tricky move
take take oh there's a funny line
I mean I gotta go for it
The Rook just gets hugged by my pieces
black has to play E5
so Bishop H3 can be played
but it might not help E5 out of H3
wait a minute
but then Bishop takes H3 wow
still tricky so maybe H4
H4 preventing Bishop H3 but then Bishop
G4
so maybe I just take the palm
or Queen's like castling
Queen side castling looks nice
I'm so conflicted here
okay I have an idea I'm gonna take
Bishop G4 King D2
that's annoying I can't access D1 it's
the only open file
but okay whites or a Black's Rook is
trapped on G2 so
it should be fine King will come to E3
at the right moment maybe I can play H3
foreign
to
have this move
that's a cool game
a very strange position there
yeah the tactics kind of worked out
nicely I mean things just got weird
when yeah when this happened
and then black on the pond
I attacked the queen and then 905
counter attack
but I think it was pretty clean overall
Bishop G4
oh it's against Miss Bishop G4 okay
yeah Bishop G4 was um
like almost kind of annoying
because there's a difference between
being trapped and being stuck
and for a while the Rooks was stuck but
I can't actually win it
instead of D takes E5 H4
oh yeah H4
wait H4 Bishop H3 I think Bishop G4 is
like just more effective
Bishop H3 runs into yeah King E2 should
be fine for whites
it should be like just winning for bites
but the reason why I didn't play H3
which is maybe a playable move is
because of Bishop takes H3
I can't take back because I lose A1 Rook
but it's possible this is like also fine
can you two check King E3 and I should
be winning this Pawn but maybe not
as a very confusing position
[Music]
five might be coming
so uh that was round oh that was round
four
already
okay so there's a break
let me find the timer
are those games still going
oh it's Fabiano
Fabiano trying to win this position
made the kings in the wrong corner
if Fabiano might actually win this
not easy to play with low time
but when was the last capture
Rook takes B4
it's impossible to scroll because it
keeps resetting
I'm trying to find the last capture I
can't though
uh
what if I use a mouse
oh 69 was the last capture
so that needs to survive until move 119.
10 more moves
wait this move
I think it's over
wow it's over
six more moves right Rook B4
wow
Aviano Unstoppable or out of four
not even a theoretically drawn ending
can stop him
so overall
how do I see my games
I mean the one game I lost I can't be
too upset about it I think it was a good
fight
the game is like one what was the first
game
oh yeah this
I wanted to check the line
so I played 94. I Rook C1
I am supposed to play G5
g5b5 F6
ah
so if H3 I'm happy to take
if Queen B3
wow what a line
this isn't so human for
like for a player to go for
to take with a rook
and then the idea
I don't understand this
if H4 there's Bishop C7 but we'll have
C6
I guess white has some compensation here
that's interesting
yeah if you're just joining
um a lot of people are playing title
choose a
it feels like a weekly World Blitz
Championship basically got Favi Magna
sakaru
of
447 title players
yeah there's two different
um tournaments
uh every Tuesday there's a morning title
Tuesday
and the afternoon title Tuesday at least
for us time
so
I see a comment how is title Tuesday
still going on
Anna kramling was playing it seven hours
ago
yeah it was maybe a couple years ago
they started implementing two
tournaments just to appeal to people in
different time zones
how many title players exist
I actually don't know the the answer you
could probably look it up on like few
days websites
although you might have to like write a
a program to scrape the data
all right
Sicilian time
who is this
another Grandmaster I haven't heard of
before
castling so D6
haven't looked at this sign in a while
it's a bit more positional
block aims to get the bishop pair and
then complete development
hmm
so the Knight doesn't get trapped it's
an ugly swear though on B7
although maybe after B4 I play Queen
Queen C7 Rook c8s attack the Knight and
prepare Knight C4
hmm
maybe preparing Queen C4
one of these moves
a couple targets
Queen C5
Queen F2
still go for it
I just plunder
Knight B5 takes takes
maybe it's okay I've worked B8 and then
hmm
super risky move
allowing takes takes Queen F7 King h8
9295 as calculation
D5 might hang in the very end there
it's actually a very nice Square for the
night
ooh
I have to take
foreign
not sure about this so takes takes takes
Bishop six
I have 95 so takes takes takes 95.
hmm
down upon
let's try this
foreign
[Music]
all right
I saw rookie Yates I didn't see Bishop
G7 checkmates oh that's unfortunate
so it's much much worse for that
I felt very close to winning back the
pawn
apparently Rook H5
it's a hard move to play
good game though
yeah pretty made for lights
not the prettiest for me
it was a good fight
very clever idea uh just play 94 in
soccer piece
box objectively better but
yeah Queen B6 is such a hard move to
play
and maintaining all the pressure
yeah when I played 95 I didn't realize
there's takes and takes
because my other candid move is Bishop
F6 which also loses a pawn
Bishop B2 I didn't even consider
that looks ridiculous but
I guess I
I don't lose material
wait what
how does this even work I'm down in
peace
ah but the Knight gets trapped
yeah Bishop just an engine move
Bishop G7
yeah I was thinking there's ideas of
like somehow trapping the knights but
and once I saw 95 it looked like the
safest option
tough game and these GMS are good at
chess
Fabiano with Five Points
just cruising
okay show those two games going
this could be a long one we're gonna see
uh Knight and Bishop versus knight
it should be a pretty simple draw for
lights but this could go 50 moves
to move 145
wow this Knight's almost trapped not
quite though
oh fancy
oh there's one other game
never mind
at least black has chased the king out
of the center
oh
okay the king's being chased
a night's getting disconnected
wait this is progress
but black has 10 more moves to either
check me or capture the Knight
King C3
I had too many checks
okay
a 50 move rule
oh that's a guy who drew Magnus yeah
good point
okay uh D4
playing Scandal God
hopefully this game won't be too
scandalous
all right
foreign
[Music]
C2
the idea is to provoke a five and then
take and then have a happy night
played these positions a lot against
Tanya and uh I'm not a GM
championship last year
wait did I just blunder a pawn
and I can take here
that wasn't intended though maybe I
should have defended F4 first
all right so takes
it takes Knight D2
a lot of Trades happening
the queen C7 is actually playable
I play Rook D1
let's go for this
oh Rook D1 Bishop E5
play Rook fd1
Bishop A4
[Music]
um
what to do with the Knights
it's not a good position
I don't see what to do there's way four
B3
play this
so threading this
H6 Queen G6
not so easy to defend the pawn actually
King F7 Queen H5
foreign
actually of takes I may maybe take here
or maybe not because Queen C5 check
okay threatening this
um
I can move
ah
let's go
unexpected Chutney too wow
oh man
I don't know how I won that
I was holding on for dear life somehow I
got counter play
black was kind of um like moving back
and forth not knowing what to do
and that gave me so many Tempe to start
pushing the the Pawns and actually
pushed these pawns way sooner
yeah already here maybe it's like it's
better for white
Queen C8 runs into check and I win The
Rook
and while the game
oh wait no there's Queen G4
one
yeah what a game
oh I'd stop being sad if you win your
next game
okay I see it I'll see what I can do
I'll play a strong player next game
four out of six
a Magnus
oh Fabiano lost
oh no my Fabiano
[Music]
yeah I have to scroll down to find me
oh chronic's still playing
chromex is black
very close to winning
but can black win the pawn
so easy cram neck has like so little
time
Jack
yeah I'd like to keep the Rook here and
then walk around with the King
seems like there's an entry point
the king doesn't do anything here
remove the last capture
move
58.
oh no there are pawn moves 87
so I think on move 137 it becomes a draw
so 12 more moves
oh it takes and then takes or check and
takes
wait why is he not taking
I was just winning though oh he just
wants to win the pawn
okay this also wins
now the 15 move rule resets
anytime a capture or pawn move is played
nice job kramnik
okay so kramnik has five points won't be
playing him
oh I'm playing this guy
this guy is also a London specialist I
wonder what he plays against London
some King's Indian thing
he knows what's coming too
oh he's probably debating E5 okay
so let's go into the the line
and this is the world's leading expert
on the sign
last time we went into the cpme so
maybe some shot at Redemption
I think group B3 is a move
some Queen A1 idea
I'm pretty sure Queenie one is playable
I might already like be taking too much
of a risk but Knight C4 Queen G7
I remember beating uh Ali resin the sign
and some Rook B5
or maybe Rook E3
Rook E3 is safer
threatening F4
[Music]
like the only time in my life I'd be Ali
Reza was it from a very similar position
it was a leech Hospital game
I I was like single or double adopted
but then all your resident went a little
bit too far and played this line
so I'm threatening F4 but I also just
want to take and transform the position
and triple Fork
get my queen as a wooden Shield
I think we'll see King F7
and what else to do for black
the key is removing this Knight though
yeah I mean this line is supposed to be
unbeatable for black but
it's risky to play especially in um
title Tuesday game with increments
okay
um I can't celebrate just yet
man I had such a similar game against
alireza
something like this happened
start with a check
Bishop D3 coming next
checking was possible but I didn't want
to give back initiative
and queen H4 ties down the kings of the
knights
there's a line
hard to make it work though
there I want to play Queen A4 at some
point
H3 first
H3 G4
H3 um Bishop D7 I have Queen H5
foreign
[Music]
still have to be careful
okay
I didn't want to let things slip I kind
of hung upon but
okay
that's how you beat the unbeatable
England Gambit
I hope you're happy now James Black
before that game James Black cheered
bits
saying this message
I'd stop being sad if you win your next
game okay
no time for sadness
what's the eval at the end
oh only plus two
only plus two wow
really
I would have thought it's more but
I guess black can still try and hold
I wanted to see the alireza game
now if I got chances there I'm not
pre-moving that
let's see his prep here
is he gonna do this funny line
what's the line look how similar this
scheme is to the game I just played
during this recently
B3
that's E3
I think I prepared this after a global
Championship because I lost
I lost in this as white
oh yeah that was a rapid game I lost
21 supposed to be completing winning
24.
yeah we followed the exact same Liars
ah but I played Rook B5 I think this is
all my prep
and then I said
it's funny though that like in that game
too I won all the pawns on the king side
it's like very very similar
okay so I'm I'm five out of seven
good score
one point behind Magnus
okay this game is Rook first Rook
so we got a small break
oh Crown neck is also playing
with all these zen games
looks like he's winning
made in nine
like you toe grinder
Crown they're coming in clutch
so he has six as well
no perfect scores
yeah a lot of the top players on six
three players with six and a half
oh there we go okay
playing a strong FM
oh wait we played
who is this
we played in some recent tournament I
think
we play in Abu Dhabi
or was it kregero
wait when did we play
I definitely played this person OTB
um
all right let's play E6
I don't know any Theory here
I know F6 is an idea
take take
seven
slightly ugly structure
hmm
[Music]
close things down
yeah this is a very foreign structure
for me
um
I feel like we played in kurgero was
that the that might have been the game
where I played against a Dutch
foreign
night moves back
wow
okay queen of four
my pawns are on the wrong color squares
that's a funny move
I just want to play Knight F7 get my
pawns on dark swears
that's not going to happen though
taking is a viable option for whites
yeah this is really ugly
I think I have to play this move just
suck a pawn and try and hold on
Rook be one I have C4
if I was a bit surprising
oh very tricky
you might see Bishop B4
it's a three result game I could try and
play this for a win
take there there
wait what am I doing
just play this
um
foreign
because I have the two passers
the bishop always controls uh A8
the king just wants to come in
if I can get the third passwords winning
it seems like this should be a draw but
it's all about past Pawns
man xqc would be so proud of this bishop
the ultimate wooden Shield
bing bing boom kapow
it's still not over though that's a good
move
okay maybe ideas of this
because King G2 will threaten C3
King F2 I take
I'm still fighting
okay that was a cool game
I felt like I was in some trouble like
even in the opening it was not a
pleasant position with this bishop
this was a funny move
but it still felt like black should be
worse
but these positions are like can be very
deceiving sometimes
because even the side who's worse can
sometimes still get chances
I have to dedicate that win to xqc
and this bishop was so um
so useful in so many ways
so six out of eight
can't remember last time I had six out
of eights entitled Tuesday
I've never performed well enough in
title Tuesday for them to like invite me
to the the fair play Zoom call
so maybe that should be my goal
oh so do that has six out of eight
same score as Judah and kramnik
I've never played chronic before
schmack is how doing well
played them last week Chicago
[Music]
is at seven out of eight and rugar keeps
winning games
Magnus also seven so who else did Magnus
draw oh Magnus
[Music]
oh
all right one thing I did want to do
is
see where I play this opponent
please Google this Reza matavi
ah we played in Abu Dhabi
oh 10 minutes ago so uh things are still
very here's the video adrenaline so this
was a um the recap I did after playing
uh this player Reza
who wait what was the game
oh yeah it was interesting game
was the result
no the A7 G1 diagonal and I forget the
results of the game
ah this was back when I was playing D6
and he played Bishop b5's check
yeah the reason why I was taking time
in the opening was I was just trying to
remember what opening we played over the
board
and it was this very deep
um Bishop E5 line
and the rare tactical idea
not to spoil the whole video I think it
was in this position but then I realized
there is a different idea in this in
this position and it's actually a pretty
rare type of tactical idea
so anyway if anyone wants to watch the
video and see what the idea was
uh I'll leave a link in the chat
it was a cool game
but okay I should get ready for
the next round
opening Darda
I think it's in the midst of playing
Sharjah
I saw some of these games from Sharjah
I can't remember which games those were
though but
I did see his name
okay
yeah
yeah this
is a slightly annoying line
Bishop G3
okay let's move first
it should be 4 A.M
and take take
F4 could be interesting
look at this move
light wants to be here
pressure A4 as well
thanks
if I want to take Now's the Time
I think I do
hmm
[Music]
I made a mistake
82 Rook D1 wow
yeah I might be in trouble here
[Music]
hmm
wasn't sure what to do
I'm just losing a pawn
oh what to do
oh I'm losing more than a pawn
I didn't see that move coming
[Music]
because yeah G5 is the threats
all right
try and fight a little bit
Down The Exchange
yeah I got a little bit too
maybe overly creative there
foreign
that's a good move let's take
good move
never resign when you have a knight
running a tricky Fork
black has to start it basically
and surviving longer than expected
which is some success
Dole my thing
dull my time okay
uh
yeah got into trouble I mean the
position was maybe close to balanced
and the black was black was doing fine
there though
how to play this position
Knight B1 was maybe too slow
engine says I should go back and change
my mind
good game though
so six out of nine
oh Hikaru against rugar so vugar June
Magnus earlier
on the verge of
and what's happening here my car is
really trying to win
or is bugar trying to win
wow
taking down your Karu
oh no my wait what
I think he was expecting King H7 there
he just gave away a night for nothing
wait what's happening
okay I don't think her car is gonna lose
this
wait what chuck oh then King H5
There is almost Lucina position
but this is a very standard draw
GG
the best move is King C7
hoping they Mouse slip this instead of
takes and then you win
but unlikely
okay
so next game oh there's still a few
games going
this
and what I did there
okay
so two more rounds
[Music]
um
some people play H6 and blunder mates
G6 is a better move though
wow
I was not expecting someone of this
reading to blunder mate into like that
it's a very weird meeting too
but it most commonly happens from this
exact line
and checkmating
in what by move 16
. wow
that's like a unique thing because
usually the F1 is defended but after
King h8
Knight F7 is just checkmate
oh
that's a painful lesson for my opponent
to learn
it's happened to me before too
I've had this probably I've had this a
good handful of times on the chess
um from varying move orders
yeah that was such a
unexpectedly quick game
for the 10th round seven out of ten
trying to catch up to Fabi and Hikaru
let's watch Magnus
oh Magnus against Favi
so what was the opening
ah this is like um
a Catalan with a weird move order
yeah this B5 line I sometimes like to
play as well
so I'm guaranteed to be playing someone
very strong next round
how many wins do you have
I guess all my games were decisive so
far
I have two losses and seven wins
so okay
within the top 30
but there's like almost all the games
are still ongoing so
uh
yeah I may have been the first scheme to
finish that round
can maybe hop around
watch rugar against sarin
wait this is
not supposed to be a great opening for
white because of 94
but an idiots
I'm curious what new Hall plays against
94 actually
but it is a Torre
wait what is this
H4 Rook H3
so he's just trying to go for the throat
G4 may be coming
ah there's a three-way tie for first
I don't think I've ever scored eight out
of 11 in title Tuesday
so
that would be the goal
I did score seven and a half last week
though
yeah I guess the strongest player I've
been today was among
knvb
but he kind of gifted me like in some
sense he he gave me a gift
because he played the queen sock line
which
as I proved is not so unbeatable
had some fun games today though
and I think all my losses maybe with
exception of the gaming as Darda but the
previous two losses were very much
fighting games
oh yeah let's watch Magnus against fobby
that's a good point
high profile players
wow so they're both falling very low on
time
I mean Fabi is probably using like eye
level opening crap
was Pawn just hanging
okay it's turning oh this pawnings yeah
it's turning into a bullet game
so fabi's up a pawn Magnus has Bishops
but so does Fabi this is a threat
oh that defends ant attacks
okay I mean this is a dream case for
Fabi outside passer
no risk of losing
Magnus is in a bit of trouble now
but confabi converts
we've seen Magnus is so resilient like
even in very close to losing positions
not just being active
this night is going on a journey might
be one maybe
Bishop has found a nice home
the problem for black I mean there's
always a worry about the Apon but
there's also weaknesses on the king side
so Fabi is trying to use the principle
of two weaknesses to
spread Magnus then
like peanut butter
the Pawn's always defended but also
block Hayden
okay the King has a
pretty clear path
yeah this this should be winning
because either the king or Knight have
to babysit the pawn
and then White's just going to crush the
king side
although yeah Knight G4 was an idea
E5
should still be winning although you
have to be careful as white trading too
many Pawns
foreign
this corner square is dark Square
because it's a right Bishop
still not over
Magnus is being so tricky Knight D5 F7
F7 anyway
GG
man that was like world class from
faviano
you should try playing in just her mints
if you try contending for the world
championship
that was a long game too
so it looks like most of the games are
complete
got one game down here
not worth watching
oh playing Chicago
[Music]
um
what does he play against
I'm trying to remember his repertoire
oh C3 okay
we're following the game I played in
Iceland
I don't think white is supposed to allow
this
um
maybe it's playable
Play Bishop E7 first
if I want to play Queen B6 and Castle
queenside as well
maybe Queen A5
I have the bishop pair better structure
to
I'm just a little bit behind the
development
we might see take 695
I probably play Queen C7 there
all right let's start with Queen A5
so controlling E5 hitting A2
I think Bishop should find a home on F6
hmm
oh that's a good move
all right
95 B4
I don't see what to do
okay not what I wanted
probably a little bit worse here
King should probably go to B7
[Music]
foreign
idea
oh no
I have to take
uh what to do
I was gonna be tough to defend
foreign
wait Rook
rookie I can't take on C3
hmm
thank you
[Music]
um
no
oh I wanted to catch him again in the
still me trap ah
oh
good game
what to do
that was a good fight
maybe Queen G1 was too risky
it's a very tricky position
I was still holding on
I miss queen my faith though
yeah it's difficult position to defend
I kind of like the opening
although he played well like
I don't think Bishop D3 is a good move
here
but White's still active and still very
playable
between 85 so this is all fine
casting Queen sign
yeah I look too risky to Castle kingside
I took a long time here
oh man I took a minute on this move
but okay I played a decent move I think
hey thank you Alexandra chess
appreciate the raid
yeah I finished
um for everyone just joining I just
finished hello Tuesday
finished with seven out of 11.
um
it was a good tournament overall had
some fun games
had some quick wins
very hard fought games against Grand
Masters
analyzing my final game against Chicago
[Music]
yeah this position looked ugly from a
distance but I guess it's fine because
C6 is always defended and E3 is still a
weakness my Bishop is decent
but the the queen Knight combination
especially in low time it's not easy
reversed
[Music]
Magnus close behind
okay let's award some Channel points
oh wow so seven was actually the leading
uh leading scorer among predicting
people
uh but more people were voting for six
and a half
but someone wages a lot of Channel
points
maybe multiple people
so seven
and complete